Abron obviously all-time scoring record
another season where you essentially
defeat father time again on a personal
level how would you evaluate the season
that you had
um
I don't know um
I'll let it play the game
I love to compete
I love to be out there for my guys my
teammates wherever I have that
particular year
um
I think it was special and the fact that
having a first year coach and first year
coaching staff to be able to take you
know take them to the Western Conference
Finals I think that's dope for Coach ham
and his coaches to have going forward
that's pretty amazing
now for me I mean I just
you know it's all about availability for
me and um keeping my mind sharp and
things of that nature
um
being present on the floor being
president you know locker room and bus
rides and plane rides things of that
nature
it was challenging it's challenging you
know for sure it was a very challenging
season
you know for me you know for our for our
ball club and obviously you know we know
what went on early on in whatever the
case may be but
now it was it was pretty cool pretty
cool ride
but I don't know I don't know I don't
know
I think it was okay I don't
like to say it's a successful year
because I don't play for anything
besides winning championships at this
point in my career and um
and I don't
I don't get a kick out of making a
conference appearance
I've done it
a lot
oh man and it's not fun to me to not be
able to be able to be a part of uh you
know get into the finals but
um
but we'll see we'll see we'll see what
happens going forward
um
I don't know
I don't know I got a lot to think about
to be honest
I had a lot to think about to be honest
and um
just for me personally going going
forward with the game of basketball
got a lot to think about
appreciate it